fantastic beasts ooh the crimes of
Grindelwald has finally been released
upon the Wizarding World
similar to all of the films from the
Harry Potter universe there's a lot to
unpack from the movie and throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything you need to know about
fantastic beasts - there will be heavy
spoilers so if you haven't seen the film
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now for everyone else
I'm definition welcome to the channel
where I ruin it so you don't have to the
first question you may have when
entering the theater is should I stick
around after the credits
unfortunately crimes of Grindelwald
doesn't have a post-credits scene so
there's no need to stick around after
the credits start rolling the movie
itself picks up with Grindelwald
escaping custody and recruiting new
followers to his course that cause is to
raise a new group of pure blooded
wizards and witches to rule over the non
magical beans that inhabit the world
there are clear allusions to the Nazi
agenda such as the Aryan race that
Hitler tried to create and I absolutely
loved that the film is laced with
political subtext and highlights towards
the dangers that a raising diversity
could lead to realizing this is Albus
Dumbledore and he unless former student
newt to help him to Walker in the waltz
plans but those who aren't caught up in
the first fantastic beasts film and you
to help the capture Grindelwald so this
clearly bad blood between the two or you
could say mud blood mud blood no no
doesn't really work the reason that
Dumbledore can't go after Grindelwald
himself is because the two used to be
lovers and they made a Blood Pact this
stops them from killing their opposite
or you could say love blood love
I'll stop altogether without now
juxtaposing this is Grindelwald who
recruits credence to go after Dumbledore
much in the same way that Dumbledore
recruits a newt by the film's end we get
arguably one of the biggest twists in
Harry Potter history we learn that
credence is in fact of the Dumbledore
bloodline this comes as a huge shock as
many believed him to be other strange
but fantastic beasts to clears this up
and confirms that he's actually
arraylist Dumbledore whilst this is
pretty much confirmed by the appearance
of a Phoenix there's actually another
theory behind this reveal that stay
and on the rolling library website which
says this could be a lie told by
Grindelwald to convince credence to go
after Albus Dumbledore after all we know
that Grindelwald is seductive and
manipulative he could be lying to
credence as he did before and if you
watch the film again note that Abernathy
and rose here changed the Lestrange
archives in the French Ministry and put
them in the Lestrange family mausoleum
we don't know if they modified them they
could have hidden something important
about credence s identity
also when Grimson is talking to
Grindelwald below the bridge he says he
killed the woman as if that's an order
why probably because the half-elf woman
knew the truth about Creedence and she
could have become a dangerous loose end
whilst there are several plot holes in
this mainly to do with the timeline
ignoring all of them it's actually a
redeeming moment for the character of
Creedence as he wants a family more than
anything
whilst I know it seems obvious the
question Grindelwald motives for why he
would reveal what he has revealed the
Creedence to me and make sense credence
is the black sheep of the family and
will probably bear a lot of it world is
more successful sibling
this rage and jealousy would ultimately
eat him down a darker path that should
he succeed in destroying his brother and
spoiler alert he does and it would drive
him fully onto the path of becoming a
dark wizard all will be revealed in the
sequels I'm sure but for now we must
theorize how things will go moving
forward and what path the future will
take characters on so what are your
thoughts on the crimes of Grindelwald do
you agree with the critics or did you
enjoy the film and what do you think of
credence is true identity comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please make sure you check
out my breakdown of this weekend's other
big boobie widows this is the channel
for people who were mad about movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]